This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。获取Bell Pure Fiber高速网络，搭配Crave、Netflix和Disney Plus，每月只需94加元起。两年期网络合约加自动扣款优惠，价格两年保持不变。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接意味着一切。我曾被囚禁九个月，此后我的一生都在探索其他人是如何在理应将他们毁灭的境遇中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特（Elizabeth Smart），而这些是……
These are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed.
这些是《幸存者档案》（The Survivor Files）。每周，我都会与那些经历过不可想象之事的幸存者在一起——他们曾被绑架、被跟踪、被控制，险些被剥夺声音。这些故事讲的是如何付出一切活著走出来。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，收听伊丽莎白·斯马特主持的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性而言同样重要，那么欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一档每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊社区，专为那些认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》具有同等讨论价值的人而设。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、BookTok（图书社群）创作者以及充满过度思考的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的各个点串联起来。是的，我着迷了。
I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Hoda Cotney, host of the
我着迷了。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，收听《Pro Society》。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的陌生人主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮涅罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行是因为这是一个难得的空间，在这里我可以不用先征求任何人的同意就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。我是霍达·柯特比（Hoda Kotb），
podcast Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbe. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you
播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》的主持人。你知道的，我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。比如我的朋友亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler）曾向有志成为演员的人、以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提供建议：你被雇佣不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间。你被雇佣是为了用你自己来填补这个空间。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，收听霍达·柯特比主持的《Joy 101》。我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Speike），欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时经历的重大变化、时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴能邀请你
back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are talking about the psychology of reputation and why it just matters so much to us as humans, particularly the role of reputation in our 20s and what it feels like when we know that people maybe don't like us, maybe have the wrong idea of us, maybe don't know us or don't think of us the way that we think of ourselves. What do we do with that information? So I got this message from a listener the other day who requested this episode. And I'm going to read it for you because, of course, I had her permission and I think it's a great description of basically the conundrum all of the issue that we are talking about today. Hi, Gemma, I have an episode topic for you that's been really heavy on my
回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁时的心理学。今天我们要讨论的是声誉心理学，以及为什么它对我们人类如此重要，特别是声誉在我们二十岁时所扮演的角色，以及当我们知道别人可能不喜欢我们、可能对我们有错误的看法、可能不了解我们或者没有像我们看待自己那样看待我们时的感受。我们该如何处理这些信息呢？几天前，我收到了一位听众的发给我的信息，她请求制作这期节目。我要把它读给你们听，因为当然，我得到了她的允许，而且我认为这是对我们今天讨论的所有问题的核心困境的一个很好的描述。嗨，杰玛，我有一个一直压在我心头的节目主题想跟你聊聊。
mind. When I was 19, I did some things I'm not proud of. I hurt friends. I wasn't a good person, and I still feel bad about it. My dad had just died and I could give you so many more excuses. for why I behaved the way I did, but I just did. I'm 24 now and I can't stop obsessing over not just the people I've hurt, but my bad reputation because of it. I recently met a new friend who I realized after a few months was friends with some of my old friends. She said to me once, you know, you are much nicer than I thought you would be, not like what people say. And I just desperately wanted to ask her, what do people say? What are they saying about being? but I guess I knew it would all be bad.
我19岁时做了一些让我引以为豪的事。我伤害过朋友。我不是个好人，到现在我依然为此感到难过。当时我爸爸刚去世，我可以为你找出更多借口，来解释我为什么会有那样的行为，但我确实做了。我现在24岁了，我无法停止纠结，不仅是因为我伤害过的人，还因为我因此而背负的坏名声。我最近结识了一个新朋友，几个月后我发现她是我的一些老朋友的朋友。她有次对我说：“你知道吗，你比我想象的要好得多，跟别人说的不一样。”我当时就非常渴望问她：“别人都说了什么？他们到底是怎么说我的？”但我猜我也知道那些话肯定都不是什么好话。
How do you deal with having a bad reputation and how do you prove to people that you have changed? It's been five years now. I want to tell them that I'm not that person anymore or is it pointless? Any advice would be helpful. And if you have read any research on this, I would love to hear it. Thank you to this listener for sharing that. That is a difficult position to be in.
你该如何应对自己拥有一个坏名声，又该如何向别人证明你已经改变了？现在已经过去五年了。我想告诉他们我不再是那个以前的人了，还是说这根本毫无意义？任何建议对我都会有帮助。如果你读过这方面的任何研究，我很希望能听听看。感谢这位听众的分享。处于那种处境确实很难。
You're kind of balancing a lot of desires and fears and also a deeper kind of moral sense. of like what is right for me to do in this situation. But you would be surprised how many messages I've gotten on a very similar note, how so many of the people have a similar dilemma, which is essentially I've made these mistakes when I didn't know better, when I was an unheeled version of myself, when I was younger, now that I'm not that person, what do I do about it? I think in my own life, even recently, I've been coming to terms with this idea of like, somebody's last impression of me, last memory of me, is somebody that I no longer am. And their last impression of me was when I was at my worst.
你某种程度上在平衡许多欲望、恐惧，还有一种更深层的道德感，比如在这个情况下我怎么做才是对的。但你会惊讶地发现，我收到了多少份内容非常相似的信息，有多少人都有着类似的困境，本质上就是：我在自己不懂事的时候、在我尚未疗愈的年轻时犯下了这些错误，现在我不再是那样的人了，我该怎么办？我想在我自己的生活中，甚至就在最近，我也一直在接受这样一个观念，那就是：别人对我的最后印象、关于我的最后记忆，是一个我早已不再是的人。他们对我的最后印象停留在我最糟糕的时候。
How do you square that with the growth that you have done, with the change that has happened in all of our lives? Let's talk about it today, because we know on a fundamental level that our reputations are important. They served and continue to serve an evolutionary purpose. They provide valuable social information to others, whether it's correct or not. but what about all the ways that reputations get complicated, like when they are inaccurate, or when they do represent somebody that we no longer are, or when people lie about us?
你该如何将这一点与你所取得的成长、以及在我们所有人生活中发生的变化协调起来？我们今天就来聊聊这个，因为我们在根本上知道，我们的声誉非常重要。它们过去曾发挥过、并且现在仍在继续发挥着进化的目的。它们为其他人提供了宝贵的社会信息，无论这些信息是否正确。但是，声誉变得复杂的种种方式又该怎么说呢，比如当它们不准确时，或者当它们代表了一个我们不再是的人时，或者当人们对我们撒谎时？
It's a big, juicy episode, I will say, without further ado, let's get into the psychology of reputation. So a reputation is basically the opinion, belief, or estimation that people hold about a person, but also about a group of people, an organization, and it's based on past behavior, it's based on character, performance, stereotypes. Some of our behaviors that have happened, some of which are assumed, some of which is subjective. Our reputation, as I briefly mentioned before, operates as kind of a mental shortcut for those around us. It's actually not that valuable to us, unless it's a good reputation, but it's a simplified version of who we are that has social capital and allows others to determine, do I want to be around this person?
这是一期内容丰富、引人入胜的节目，话不多说，我们这就切入声誉心理学。所以，声誉基本上是人们对一个人、但也可以是对一群人或一个组织所持有的意见、信念或评价，它是基于过去的表现、性格、表现、刻板印象。我们发生过的一些行为，其中有些是假定的，有些则是主观的。正如我之前简要提到的那样，我们的声誉对我们周围的人来说是一种心理捷径。除非这是个好名声，否则它对我们其实没有那么大价值，但它是我们是谁的简化版本，具有社会资本，并允许其他人决定：我想和这个人在一起吗？
Do I want to let them into the group? Do I want to give them a job? Do I want to be their friend? Do I want to date them or not? And it is tangible in the way that it directly influences our lives. It is intangible in the way that our reputation is not controlled by some central database. And it can exist differently for different people, even if there are some stable themes or stable ideas of who we are that are generally wide held, people can still differ in how they see us. Now, our reputation has levels to it. Some parts of our reputation is influenced by things we've actually done. That is level one. It is action driven. Some of it is influenced by secondary assessments, i.e. things we haven't done, but also how someone has interpreted our actions
我想让他们加入这个群体吗？我想给他们一份工作吗？我想成为他们的朋友吗？我想和他们约会吗？它在直接影响我们生活的方式上是具体存在的；而在我们的声誉并不受某个中央数据库控制的方式上，它又是抽象的。对于不同的人来说，它的存在方式可以不同，即使关于我们是谁有一些普遍稳定的主题或稳定的想法被广泛认可，人们在看待我们时仍然会有所不同。现在，我们的声誉是有层次的。我们声誉的一部分受我们实际做过的事情的影响。这是第一层。它是行动驱动的。其中一部分受二级评估的影响，即我们没有做过的事情，但也包括某人如何根据他们自己的价值观、他们自己的视角来解释我们的行为，
based on their own values, based on their own perspectives, how stories about us have changed as they've been repeated. And I guess also situations where people haven't had the full information, but they've either made up additional information or made assumptions or deducted something about us based on stereotypes that are not true. That is level two. That is the subjective social evaluation level of reputation. Research that has been done into reputations, because it's a massive field of social psychology, shows that there are a few universal features across all societies that define reputation, particularly with regards to how cooperative people are perceived. Whilst there are widespread similarities across societies, reputations are also
以及关于我们的故事在被重复讲述时是如何发生改变的。我想还有一些情况是，人们并没有完全的信息，但他们要么凭空捏造了额外的信息，要么做出了假设，或者根据并不真实的身分刻板印象对我们做出了推断。这是第二层。这是声誉的主观社会评价层。对声誉进行的研究——因为这是社会心理学的一个庞大领域——表明，所有社会中都存在一些定义声誉的普遍特征，特别是关于人们的合作程度如何被感知。尽管各社会之间存在广泛的相似性，但声誉也是
culturally constructed. They are shaped by local norms and values, even though they would emerge from what we'd referred to as universal psychology. Some factors of it aren't. Some factors of reputation seem to be universal. Others definitely differ. In 2021, researchers look through a huge ethnographic record of more than 100 diverse societies to find what they called the 20 distinct reputational domains.
文化构建的。它们由当地的规范和价值观塑造，尽管它们可能源于我们所称的普遍心理学。声誉的某些因素并非如此。声誉的某些因素似乎是普遍的。其他的则绝对不同。在2021年，研究人员查阅了来自100多个不同社会的庞大民族志记录，以寻找他们所谓的20个不同的声誉领域。
And they found them. What they found was that these included things like aggressiveness, cooperation, cultural conformity, honesty, honesty, sexual fidelity, social status, and supernatural ability. These things seem to influence
他们确实找到了。他们发现这些领域包括攻击性、合作性、文化顺从、诚实、性忠诚、社会地位以及超自然能力。这些事情似乎都会影响
reputation, no matter where you were. The research has discovered that in over 80% of the societies they examined, a good reputation typically had a few critical things. It involved being cooperative, pro-social, honest,
声誉，无论你在哪里。研究发现，在他们调查的80%以上的社会中，好名声通常具备几个关键要素。它包括具有合作精神、亲社会性、诚实、
norm-abiding, and industrious. A bad reputation also followed a similar theme. It usually contained traits like dishonesty, aggressiveness, harm towards others, and actions that disrupted social harmony. So there seems to be this universal sense of what makes a good community member, and this is carried by our reputation.
守规矩和勤奋。坏名声也遵循相似的主题。它通常包含不诚实、攻击性、对他人造成伤害以及破坏社会和谐的行为。因此，似乎存在一种关于什么样的人才算好的社区成员的普遍共识，而这一点是通过我们的声誉承载的。
There is a critical behavior, though, that really seems to stand out more than any of the others when it comes to a bad reputation. This is dishonesty. And not just dishonesty, but dishonesty and hypocrisy. people strangely are more okay with somebody's behavior if they're at least honest about it. If they're at least kind of upfront that like, hey, I'm going to be an asshole. I'm going to behave in ways that you might not like. But at least I'm going to be honest with you.
不过，有一个关键行为在涉及坏名声时，似乎比其他任何行为都更为突出。这就是不诚实。不仅是不诚实，还有不诚实和虚伪。奇怪的是，如果一个人对自己的行为至少是诚实的，人们反而更能接受。如果他们至少在某种程度上坦诚地说：“嘿，我就是个混蛋。我会做出你们可能不喜欢的事情。但至少我会对你们诚实。”
We seem to be less okay if you're an asshole and you pretended that you weren't. If you didn't give it any kind of hint that that was going to be the case. It's why celebrities who are like have these identities and these reputations is being kind of of dicks. Like, we're kind of less mad at them compared to celebrities who claim to be really nice but then are secretly assholes, hence the kind of pushback against Ellen DeGeneres, for example. It's because what they are doing in psychology is called false signaling. This one 2017 paper published in the journal Psychological Sciences found that people generally assess hypocrites, which is who these people are, more negatively than someone who has done or who has genuine
如果我们是个混蛋却假装自己不是，如果我们没有流露出任何这方面的迹象，我们似乎就更无法接受。这就是为什么那些拥有这种身份和坏蛋名声的名人，我们对他们的愤怒反而比那些声称自己非常好但私底下却是混蛋的名人要少一些，因此也就有了针对艾伦·德杰尼勒斯（Ellen DeGeneres）等人的这种抵制。这是因为他们在心理学中所做的事情被称为“虚假信号”。2017年发表在《心理学科学》杂志上的一篇论文发现，人们对伪君子（也就是这些人）的评价，总体上要比对那些有明确负面道德观点但不对其撒谎的人的评价更负面。
in negative moral opinions but doesn't lie about it. So dishonesty and hypocrisy seems to be the universal reputational sin, the way that cooperativeness seems to be the universal positive reputational asset. The other thing that seems to really deeply impact how your reputation is formed is not just your actions and whether you're dishonest or hypocrite or cooperative. And it's not your intentions. It's how you make others feel. It's a very famous. It's a very famous quote from Maya Angelou, people will forget what you said, people will forget what you did, but people will never forget how you made them feel. And that holds up very accurately under science. Essentially, it's impossible for us to remember every single thing we have ever said
因此，不诚实和虚伪似乎是普遍的声誉罪过，就像合作精神似乎是普遍的积极声誉资产一样。另一件真正深刻影响你声誉形成的事情，不仅是你的行为以及你是否不诚实、虚伪或具有合作精神，也不是你的意图，而是你如何让其他人产生感觉。这是玛雅·安杰卢（Maya Angelou）的一句非常著名的名言：人们会忘记你说的，人们会忘记你做的，但人们永远不会忘记你带给他们的感觉。这句话在科学上同样非常准确。本质上，我们不可能记住我们对另一个人说的每一句话，
to another person, or indeed what they've said about us. We cannot keep an ongoing catalog of every person's actions because our memory and our working memory is limited. But what we can remember is the distinct emotional response that somebody invoked in us at a specific time. Our mind encodes memories and moments of emotional pain, of deceit, of betrayal, of sadness, almost in a different way to the average experiences we have. Making it so those moments are consolidated faster, deeper, and more. with more detail. It doesn't matter your intention. It doesn't matter what you say after the fact or if you apologize. The emotional aftertaste of a bad experience with somebody lingers because of how
或者他们关于我们说的每一句话。我们无法为每个人的行为保留一份持续更新的目录，因为我们的记忆和工作记忆是有限的。但我们能记住的是，某人在特定时间激起我们的独特情绪反应。我们的心灵编码记忆和痛苦、欺骗、背叛、悲伤的时刻的方式，几乎与我们经历的普通体验不同。这使得这些时刻的巩固速度更快、更深，且带有更多细节。你的意图并不重要。事后你说什么或是否道歉并不重要。由于记忆是如何构建的，与某人经历不愉快之后的残余情绪会挥之不去，特别是如果你让他们对自己的感觉非常糟糕的话。
memory is constructed, especially if you made them feel really bad about themselves. I think somewhere this comes across very strongly is our experiences as children. And the fact that people who were cruel to us, mean to us, belittled us, those memories last a very long time. They're very hard to shake. Of course, we still do it in adulthood, even when we know that our subjective interpretation may not be accurate. Even when we know people are capable of change or we're just having a bad day, but as children, memories and bad memories seem to really, really stick. You know, every day we have lots of fleeting interactions with people. people that leave a bit of a stamp on us with the person on the train or the person who made
我想在某种程度上，这一点表现得最强烈的就是我们作为孩子的经历。那些对我们残酷、对我们不好、贬低我们的人，那些记忆会持续很长时间。它们很难被抹去。当然，我们在成年期仍然会这样做，即使我们知道我们的主观解释可能并不准确。即使我们知道人们有能力改变，或者我们只是度过了糟糕的一天，但作为孩子，记忆和糟糕的记忆似乎真的、真的很难消除。你知道，每天我们都会与人们进行许多短暂的互动，这些互动在火车上的人、给你做咖啡的人或你的新同事身上给我们留下了印记。第一印象，特别是关于我们情绪状态的第一印象，确实很重要。我们从研究中得知，人们可以在短短五秒钟内形成观点，不是因为你给了他们大量的信息供其依赖，而是因为我们本能地信任直觉，尤其是我们自己的直觉。
your coffee or your new co-worker. And first impressions, particularly in regards to our emotional state, do matter. We know from research, people can form an opinion within literally five seconds, not because you've given them a wealth of information to rely on, but because we instinctively trust gut feelings, especially our own. And once we have a gut feeling, it's very hard to replace. It is a bit of a human flaw, though. It might be protective. It is evolutionary. It is sometimes not always conscious. In fact, it's rarely conscious. But the floor of first impressions is that it doesn't let people surprise us. And people can surprise us. First impressions are rarely accurate. They are extremely layered and they are often extremely personal. And people are very much
一旦我们有了直觉，就很难再被取代。不过，这确实有点像人类的缺陷。它可能具有保护作用。它是进化的产物。它有时并不总是有意识的。事实上，它很少是有意识的。但第一印象的缺陷在于，它不允许人们给我们带来惊喜。而人们是可以给我们带来惊喜的。第一印象很少是准确的。它们包含极其丰富的层次，而且往往极其个人化。人们完全有能力改变。但我们并不总是能用这种更深层的、情感上的感觉去讲道理。而且，你知道，有时我们不想这么做，有时我们也不应该被迫这么做。你知道，我可能还要补充一点。我刚说第一印象并不总是准确的。不过，有时人们确实做了错事，他们是真的心狠手辣，他们不想修正自己的错误。
capable of change. But we can't always reason with this deeper emotional. feeling. And, you know, sometimes we don't want to and sometimes we shouldn't have to. You know, I might also add that. I say first impressions aren't always accurate. Sometimes though people do the wrong thing, they really mean they're cruel, they don't want to fix their mistakes. And that feeling, no matter what they do, does linger. And it might be for a good reason. But we also have to be aware of some of the other biases that show up in reputational psychology that mean our first impressions aren't always correct. Stereotypes and prejudice just play a massive role. You can be completely delightful and kind and respectful and industrious and
而那种感觉，无论他们做什么，都会挥之不去。这可能是有充分理由的。但我们也必须意识到声誉心理学中出现的其他一些偏差，这些偏差意味着我们的第一印象并不总是正确的。刻板印象和偏见起着巨大的作用。你可以完全讨人喜欢、善良、尊重他人、勤奋且和谐。但如果有人就是不喜欢长得像你或听起来像你的人，你永远都不可能赢。这对我们所有人来说都是一个很好的警示，即我们对声誉的依赖是有缺陷的。无论我们是否愿意承认，我们对声誉的依赖往往大约有50%是关于我们自己的，50%是关于别人的。有时甚至还不止于此。有时它更多地是关于我们过去的信念、过去的经历和过去的伤害。
harmonious. But if someone just doesn't like people who look like you or sound like you, you are never going to win. And that is a good warning to us all, that our reliance on reputation is flawed. Our reliance on reputation, whether we like to admit it or not, is often about 50% about us and 50% about somebody else. And sometimes it's more than that. Sometimes it's more about our past beliefs, our past experiences and past hurts. And it's not entirely accurate about how this person actually is. Also, on the flip side, and this deserves mentioning,
而且它并不完全准确地反映这个人实际上是什么样的人。另外，在另一方面，这绝对值得一提，根据与他们的性格毫无关系的事情（例如他们的外表），我们往往会认为人们更友善或拥有更好的声誉。这是我们并不总是看到被公开讨论的这方面的另一个层面。我想更详细地谈谈这种偏见。我们先稍作休息，然后深入探讨。获取Bell Pure Fiber高速网络，搭配Crave、Netflix和Disney Plus。每月只需94加元起。两年期网络合约加自动扣款优惠，价格两年保持不变。
we tend to think people are nicer or have better reputations based on things that have absolutely nothing to do with their character, such as their appearance. This is another aspect of this that we don't always see spoken about. I want to talk about this bias specifically in a bit more detail. We're going to take a short break first, and then we'll get into it. Get Bell, Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus. From $94 a month, price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit.
访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接意味着一切。我14岁时被绑架，并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，我的一生都在探索其他人是如何在理应将他们毁灭的境遇中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特（Elizabeth Smart），这些是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边传来一个低沉、嘲弄的声音，说：闭嘴，什么也别说。每周，我都会与那些经历过不可想象之事的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。
Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped, and held captive for nine months. I survived and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart and these are the survivor files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, Without a doubt, he was going to hurt me.
我开始觉得床脚好像站着一个人，然后我就开始尖叫。他们曾被绑架、被跟踪、被控制，险些被剥夺声音。但这些故事讲的不是他们被夺走了什么。而是讲他们如何付出一切活著走出来。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，收听伊丽莎白·斯马特主持的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性而言同样重要，那么欢迎回家。这里是《Pro Society》，这是一档每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊社区，专为思想先锋、流行文化痴迷者，以及认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等讨论水平的人而设。我是埃莉·拉洛（Eli Rallo），每周我们都在将书籍、互联网以及每个人都在热议的话题联系起来。
I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsesives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having.
我得去查查这个故事。我着迷了。正如某个人所说。从畅销书作家和您最喜爱的BookTok创作者，到最新的流行文化时刻，一切皆有可能。这就像如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的讯息，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度探讨、明智的流行文化对话，还是渴望一个喜欢过度思考的读者社区，你都来对地方了。
I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. As someone says. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place.
在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。在字里行间再见。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的陌生人主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮涅罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行是因为这是一个难得的空间，在这里我可以不用先征求任何人的同意就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。每次我试图独处时，我总会遇到人，他们会说：“你朝我们笑了。”
Listen to pro society on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinheiro, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us.
这里很少有人笑。正是在你独自一人时，你对世界的本原最具接受力，而不是对兜售给你的谎言最具接受力。这可以是一段你突破自我极限、改变想法或唤醒全新自己的时光。因此，无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是紧张得不敢预订第一次旅行，我都希望你在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们在大钱玩家网络（Big Money Players Network）主持播客节目《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。
Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is, and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook,
我们的节目对第一次听的听众非常友好。每周，我们都会与演艺界（也就是业内）的某个人交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，并看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，
on the Big Money Players Network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time,
没有人会因为他们的公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·谢尔曼（Sarah Sherman）。没那么优秀。其实，你能帮我，你能帮我塑造这个吗？我们把这颠倒过来怎么样？
and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman. Not that great. Actually, can you help me, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head?
我们把这个剧本翻转一下怎么样？那个你原本以为是“直男/正常人”的搞笑女人，其实才是行为怪异的那个人，会怎么样？亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott），你这一整天都期待着亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）来节目做客。我绝不会期待。我有。我绝不会对发生这种事抱有任何期望。如果宇宙允许发生这种事。我持开放态度。
How about we flip this script? What is the surprise woman who actually you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird? Adam Scott, this entire time you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to visit the show. I would never expect. I have. I would never set expectations for something like that to happen. If the universe allows for something like that to happen. I'm open to it.
我总是会接受的。你知道，丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride），好吧。是的，全是这种脆弱的男子气概。散发出来。老实说，我走在走廊里就能闻到。我想，那是大麻吗？不，那是脆弱的男子气概。本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），不。
I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah, it's all this fragile masculinity. Exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, is that weed? Nope, it's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no.
因为很多时候，脱离了语境，人们根本不理解，甚至不知道什么是圈子。你知道我的意思吗？他们太蠢了。每个人都很蠢，除了你。而且很虚伪。对，很虚伪。而且不感兴趣，或者只是觉得，哦，我有我自己的生活。
Because a lot of times, out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? They're so stupid. Everyone's so dumb, except for you. And fake. Right, fake. and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got my life.
我才不管你的生活呢。还有许多如果没有我们根本不会有今天的其他大人物。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）亲自告诉我们他很喜欢这个节目，并且他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他实在太忙了。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Hollywood Handbook》。我们最初留给人们的印象，特别是在我们的吸引力方面，实际上对其他人与我们联系在一起的特质有着深远的影响。所以这就是我们的声誉。
I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. How we first appear to people, particularly in terms of our attractiveness, actually has a profound impact upon traits that others associate with us. So our reputation.
这个现象有一个名字。它被称为“光环效应”（Halo Effect），并且它无处不在。在20世纪20年代进行的心理学早期关于声誉的研究中，心理学家爱德华·桑代克（Edward Thorndyke）要求军官根据智力、领导力和性格等品质对士兵进行评级。但这里有一个转折。许多军官几乎不认识他们正在评判的人。他们根本不知道这些人里有一半是谁。有时他们甚至不知道这些人的名字。桑代克发现的是，如果一个士兵外表看起来令人印象深刻，军官们就会自动认为他更聪明、更有能力、更值得信赖。一个好的、
There is a name for this. It's called the Halo Effect, and it is absolutely everywhere. In one of psychology's earliest studies on reputation done in the 1920s, the psychologist Edward Thorndyke asked military officers to rate their soldiers on traits like intelligence, leadership and character. But there was a twist to this. Many of the officers barely knew the men they were judging. They had no clue who half these people were. They sometimes didn't even know their names. What Thorndyke discovered was that if a soldier looked physically impressive, officers automatically assumed he was smarter, he was more competent, he was more trustworthy. One good,
有吸引力的品质，会在其他一切事物上投射出一种心理光芒。这就是他将其称为“光环效应”的原因。一个多世纪后，它仍然塑造着谁被雇用、谁得到晋升、谁被信任。甚至包括我们选择关注谁，在特定情况下谁被视为恶棍与受害者。现在，在过去的几十年里，这种效应已经在许多研究中被观察到并重复出现。在2023年的一项针对近3000名参与者的的大型研究中发现，在图片上使用美颜滤镜后，同一个人获得的智力、可信度、社交能力和幸福感评分要显著高得多。有趣的是，这也很受性别影响。该研究还发现，与女性相比，经过美颜的男性在感知智力方面获得了显著更高的分数。
attractive quality, cast a kind of psychological glow over everything else. And that's why he called it the halo effect. And more than a century later, it's still shapes who gets hired, who gets promoted, who gets trusted. Even like who we choose to follow, who is seen as a villain versus a victim in certain situations. Now this effect has been seen and repeated in many studies in the decades since In 2023, a large study of almost 3,000 participants found that the same individuals received significantly higher ratings of intelligence, trustworthiness, sociability and happiness after having applied a beauty filter on a picture of themselves. Interestingly, this was also quite gendered. The study also found that beautified men received significantly higher scores to their perceived intelligence compared to women. yet another example of reputation being shaped by things that have very little to do with our character
这又是一个声誉被那些与我们的性格几乎没有关系、然而人们却下意识地认为有关系的事情所塑造的例子。我们必须对此有极高的警惕，你知道的，特别是通过社交媒体，特别是鉴于我们可以如此瞬间改变外表的方式，有时我们仍然采纳了许多捷径，而这些捷径并不准确。其中之一就是：如果某人的外表长成某种特定样貌，他们身上的某些部分就突然变得好得多。我们可以看到这与恐肥症等问题是如何联系在一起的，与天哪，由于偏见、刻刻板印象以及我们大脑所走的捷径，我们在社会中存在的许多其他社会问题联系在一起。这是关于声誉的关键点。
and yet people unconsciously assume they do. We have to be super aware of this, you know, especially with social media, especially with the way that we can change our appearance. So instantaneously at times, we still adopt so many shortcuts that aren't our shortcuts that aren't accurate. One of them being, if somebody looks a certain way, parts of who they are must suddenly be a lot better. And we can see how this links to things like fat phobia, links to, God, so many other kind of social issues that we have in society because of, again, prejudices, stereotypes, shortcuts that our mind makes. This is the critical thing about reputation. we think of it as being this generalizable thing where we can label somebody with three or four
我们认为它是一个可以概括的东西，我们可以用三四个词来给某人贴上标签，而所有认识他们的人都会同意这些词，甚至可能是一个所有人都会同意的词，他们是个骗子、他们很贪婪、他们很善良、他们很安静，但你与每个人或每个群体拥有的声誉很可能会略有不同，会有其自身的风味，你知道的，人们对你的看法可能完全不同。它似乎并不是稳定的，即使我们某种程度上相信它是稳定的。这就解释了为什么同一个人可能会被一个群体崇拜，而被另一个群体憎恨，以及为什么两个人可以对某人形成截然不同的看法，并根据完全相同的互动传播关于某人的截然不同的名声。例如，一个声音很大的人可能会被一个人喜爱，
words and everybody who knows them would agree on those words, maybe even one word everybody would agree on, they are a liar, they're greedy, they're kind, they're quiet, but the reputation you have with each person or each group will likely be a little bit different will have its own flavor, you know, we'll have, people could think. about you entirely different. It seems that it's not stable even if we kind of believe that it is. And this explains why someone can be adored by one group hated by another and why two people can form very different opinions of somebody and spread a very different reputation of someone based on the exact same interactions. For example, someone who is very loud might be loved
认为他是一个喜欢热闹、擅长社交、有幽默感、有个人魅力且温暖的人。这可能部分是因为（你知道的）他们因为成长于一个大家庭、从小身边有很多非常吵闹的人的经历，而将吵闹的人与积极的情感联系在一起。所以他们不认为对方是个威胁。然后一个完全不同的人走进来，看到完全相同的事情，不喜欢吵闹的人，就会觉得他们的名誉和他们本身是盛气凌人的、势不可挡的、是和平的破坏者。也许他们把那个吵闹的人与他们认识的某个霸凌过他们的人，或者他们认识的除了吵闹之外还具有非常负面特质的人联系在一起。所以这让他们对吵闹的人自然产生不信任。
by one person as a person who was up for a good time, who was social, who has a good sense of humour, who was charismatic and warm. This might be in part because, you know, they associate loud people with positive feelings because of their history of being in a big family and being around very loud people when they were growing up. So they don't see them as a threat. And then an entirely different person can walk in, see the exact same things, not like loud people and be like their reputation who they are is overbearing, overwhelming, a disturber of the peace. Maybe they associate that loud person with somebody they knew who bullied them or somebody they knew who had really negative traits alongside being loud. So it makes them naturally
谈到别人如何看待我们时，这并不总是准确的。我知道我之前提到过社交媒体，但我确实认为它也带来了一种全新的动态，我们可以坐在那里评估某人的行为，而他们对此没有任何发言权。我们可以根据几秒钟的内容或从长达一小时的对话中剪切下来的片段，或者从一生的截图中形成一种观点。可以说，当今的社交媒体气候使声誉管理变得更加复杂。因此，这是非名人不得不考虑的事情。就像，我们以前不需要像现在这样广泛地思考它。你知道的，在任何阶段，都可能有人拍摄你做某事，
distrustful of loud people. When it comes to the way others view, us, like, it's not always accurate. And I know I mentioned social media before, but I do think it's also added a whole new dynamic where we can sit and assess somebody's behavior without them having any say in it. We can form an opinion based on seconds of content or footage sliced down from an hour-long conversation or sliced down from an entire life. The social media climate today has arguably made reputation management much more complex. And so, something that non-celebrities have to think about. Like, we didn't have to think about it that broadly the way that we do now. You know, at any stage, somebody can film you doing something,
有人会来访问你的主页，有人会编辑你所说的话、视频或你的照片，无论公平与否，这都会改变人们对你的看法。你知道的，人们在我们的日常生活中捕捉到的内容可能会突然疯传，并且会做出评判。通常是在没有任何事实依据的情况下，特别是在记录了高度情绪化的情境，或者记录了高度病毒式传播或类似触发剧情的情境时。此外，如果我们认为我们的声誉就是我们在不在房间里时别人对我们说的话，那么由于社交媒体的存在，现在几乎有无限数量的房间存在，只要算法碰巧推送了我们的照片或者某人截了图，我们的名字就可能在这些房间里被谈论。如果你有一个公开的Instagram、公开的LinkedIn或公开的TikTok，你的脑海深处通常会有这样一种想法：根据他们在这里看到的东西，别人是怎么看我的？这对我认为的自己是一个准确的评估吗？
somebody can come and visit your page, somebody can edit what you've said or a video or a photo of you, and whether it's fair or unfair, it's going to change how people think about you. You know, content that people capture of us amid our day-to-day lives can suddenly go viral, and judgments can be made. often without many facts, particularly when highly emotive situations are recorded or highly viral or like triggering situations are recorded. Additionally, if we think of our reputation as what other people say about us when we're not in the room, because of social media, there are now nearly infinite number of rooms in existence that our name
我认为这让声誉在这些天感觉像是一个更大、更重要的概念，因为在任何阶段，在任何时间，都可能有人在暗中查看你的个人资料并做出评估。你知道的，我喜欢这个人吗？这是我会约会的那种人吗？这是我会与之交友的那种人吗？这个非常有限的信息告诉我，我是否应该邀请这个人去我的派对，我是否应该给这个人一份工作？诸如此类，不胜枚举。你知道，这就是为什么我带着如此嫉妒的目光看待那些不用社交媒体的人，因为只有被那些你想与之相处的人了解和观察，在某种程度上保持一种无法触及和无法企及的状态，这里面有着巨大的自由。我想回到我之前提到的一点，在我太快地掠过它之前，那就是：一个糟糕的时刻、一个糟糕的决定，就有可能毁掉你整个名声。我们可以举一个病毒式视频的例子。这绝对是一个完美的例子，你可以看到某些人在争论、踢小狗、舔甜甜圈（如果你懂那个梗的话），或者某人只是做了
could be spoken about in if the algorithm just happens to push out a photo of us or somebody screenshots, something. If you have a public Instagram or a public LinkedIn or a public TikTok, there is often this thought in the back of your mind, like, what did people think about me based on what they see here? And is it an accurate assessment of who I think I am? And I think that makes reputation feel like a much bigger, more important idea these days, because at any stage, at any time, there could be somebody stalking your profile and coming up with an assessment. You know, do I like this person? Is this the kind of person I would date? Is this the kind of person I'd be. friends with. What does this very limited information tell me about whether I should invite this person
某些事，然后他们的名声就彻底完蛋了。我觉得柯普利（Copa-lied）出轨丑闻就是这种事情发生得有多快的一个很好例子。很多人会声称这很不公平，为什么一个时刻比其他一千个某人表现良好、某人没有做坏事的时刻更重要？为什么那个时刻不作数呢，他们可能会说？为什么这一个重大时刻如此重要？好吧，为什么那些重大的孤立行动在声誉生态系统中显得如此巨大，相比于你做过的数百万件好事或中立的事情，原因在于一个特殊的成分，那就是信任。
to my party, whether I should give this person a job? The list goes on. You know, that's why I look at people with social media with so much jealousy, because there is so much freedom in only being known and observed by those you would like to be around, of being kind of unreachable and untouchable, in a sense. I want to return to something. I mentioned earlier, before I rushed past it way too quickly, which is the idea that one bad moment, one bad decision is capable of ruining your entire reputation. We could give the example of a viral video. It's the perfect example of that where, you know, you see videos of somebody arguing or kicking a puppy or licking a donut if you get that reference or somebody just doing
这也是因为我们所谓的“暴露性格的时刻”的重要性，这又回到了关于虚伪和不诚实的那个观点。人们希望你首先坦诚地表明自己是谁，即使你的本性是个混蛋。这些滑动门时刻将这一切都抛向了问号之中，这就是为什么它们感觉如此意义重大。
something and it's like their reputation is done for. I feel like the co-played cheating scandal was a great example of how fast that can happen. A lot of people will claim it's unfair that one moment means more than a thousand other moments where somebody was good, somebody wasn't doing something bad. Like, why doesn't that count, they may say? Why is this one big moment so important? Well, the reason those big one-off actions loom so large in the reputational ecosystem in comparison to the millions of good things or neutral things you've done
这种信任很难赢回来。你对某人不忠，你对朋友做了一件可怕的事。这很难挽回，因为你做出这种事的潜力已经被暴露了。并且人们会假设你骨子里一直都是这样，而你之前一直在撒谎。作为人类，由于一种被称为“负面偏误”（negativity bias）的现象，我们的生理机制也让我们更容易去关注那些重大时刻。这个词是由心理学家保罗·罗森（Paul Rosen）和爱德华·罗伊斯曼（Edward Royzman）在2001年提出的。罗森和赖斯曼，我知道这是做合作伙伴的完美名字。
is because of one special ingredient, and that is trust. It's also because of the significance of what we call character revealing moments, and it links back to that point about hypocrisy and dishonesty. People want you to be up front about who you are, first and foremost, even if who you are as an asshole. These sliding door moments throw all of that into question, and that's why they feel so significant.
是因为一种特殊的成分，那就是信任。这也与我们所说的“性格暴露时刻”的重要性有关，它与关于虚伪和不诚实的观点联系在一起。人们希望你首先坦诚地展现真正的自己，即使你是个混蛋。这些“滑动门”时刻让这一切都受到了质疑，这就是为什么它们显得如此重要。
That trust is hard to get back. You cheat on somebody, you do something terrible to a friend. It's hard to get that back because your capacity for doing such things has been revealed. And it's assumed it was always in you and you were lying about it. As human beings, we're also hardwired to pay attention to those big moments more because of something known as the negativity bias. This was coined in 2001 by the psychologist Paul Rosen and Edward Royzman. Rosen and Reisman, I know perfect names to be collaborators.
这种信任很难挽回。你背叛了某人，或者对朋友做了一件可怕的事。这很难挽回，因为你做这种事的潜质已经暴露了。人们会认为你骨子里一直都是这样，而你之前一直在说谎。作为人类，由于一种被称为“消极偏见”的现象，我们的基因也让我们更倾向于关注那些重大时刻。这个词是由心理学家保罗·罗森和爱德华·罗伊兹曼在2001年提出的。罗森和雷斯曼，我知道这是绝佳的合作者名字。
But, you know, like so much of our behavior, negativity bias, like, is about survival. And what it basically says is that if we pay attention to the worst stuff and we think of that as more important, we will be safer. You know, hundreds of years ago, having heightened attention to bad, dangerous negative threats or bad, dangerous, negative people in day-to-day life was very important. It could be a matter of life and death. So those who noticed danger or bad reputations and paid more attention to that, they were more likely to survive. Neuroscience research has shown that there is greater neural processing in the brain in response to negative stimuli. In studies conducted by even more psychologists, there's always more, participants were shown pictures of either positive, negative or neutral images. The researchers then, I think they like observe electrical activity in the brain.
但是，你知道的，就像我们的许多行为一样，消极偏见实际上与生存有关。它基本上说明的是，如果我们关注最糟糕的事情，并认为它更重要，我们就会更安全。你知道的，在几百年前，在日常生活中对不好、危险的消极威胁或不好、危险、消极的人保持高度关注是非常重要的。这可能是生死攸关的大事。因此，那些注意到危险或坏名声并给予更多关注的人，他们更有可能生存下来。神经科学研究表明，大脑在对消极刺激做出反应时会有更多的神经处理。在更多心理学家的研究中（总是有更多研究），参与者被展示了积极、消极或中性的图片。然后研究人员，我想他们就像是观察大脑中的电活动。
And what they found was that negative images produced a much stronger response, particularly in the frontal low, but in the executive functioning and thinking parts of the brain. Because negative information causes such a surge in activity in such a critical information processing area, our behaviors and attitudes tends to be shaped more powerfully by, as I said, the bad stuff, the bad news, the bad experiences, the bad one off, then all the other good times that may outnumber it thousandfolds. So someone who makes a big mistake, whether they were having a bad day or not, whether they regret it now or not, whether that's who they are fundamentally or not, that big mistake is going to be remembered because of our brain's heart.
而他们发现的是，消极图片会产生强得多的反应，尤其是在额叶，还有大脑中负责执行功能和思考的部分。由于消极信息在这样一个关键的信息处理区域引起了活动的激增，正如我所说，我们的行为和态度往往更容易被最糟糕的事情、坏消息、糟糕的经历、糟糕的一次性事件所强烈塑造，而不是成千上万倍于它的所有其他美好时光。因此，一个犯了重大错误的人，无论他们当时是否度过糟糕的一天，无论他们现在是否后悔，无论这是否是他们本质上的为人，那个重大错误都会被记住，因为我们的大脑。
wiring. So is this forever? Does our reputation ever change back? Or is it permanent? This is really where we are getting into our listener question, isn't it? What do I do about past mistakes? How do I convince people I'm not that anymore? There's a famous quote from Warren Buffett, like the billionaire, in which he says it takes 20 years to build a reputation. It takes five minutes to ruin it. If you think about that, you'll do things differently. I think that's the full quote. This is the critical part about reputation. It can change instantly, often in a negative direction.
连线。那么，这是永远的吗？我们的名声还会变回来吗？还是永久的？这确实是我们进入听众提问的时候了，不是吗？我该如何处理过去的错误？我怎么才能让别人相信我不再是那样的人了？沃伦·巴菲特（比如那个亿万富翁）有一句名言，他说建立名声需要20年。毁掉它只需要五分钟。如果你仔细想想，你做事的方式就会有所不同。我想这就是完整的引文。这是关于名声的关键部分。它可以在瞬间改变，通常是向消极的方向发展。
The positive direction is a long game and requires very few mistakes. The reason reputation, once injured, is hard to reclaim. Not impossible, though. It's not impossible. I promise we'll get to that in a second. But why it's hard to reclaim is because of two additional biases. bias is everywhere in this episode. It is the confirmation bias and the recency bias, and this is why we sometimes feel stuck with the reputation we had at 19 or 18. Firstly, confirmation bias is the
积极的方向是一场持久战，需要极少的错误。名声一旦受损就很难挽回的原因。不过也不是不可能。这并非不可能。我保证我们一会儿就会讲到这一点。但之所以难以挽回，是因为另外两个偏见。偏见在这期节目中到处都是。这就是确认偏见和近因偏见，这就是为什么我们有时会觉得被自己19岁或18岁时的名声所困扰。首先，确认偏见是
tendency to search for, interpret, and recall information that confirms what we already think. If we form an opinion that someone is judgmental, even neutral things they say, we will interpret as matching our preconceived notion of them. They could say, hey, where did you get that shirt? Neutral question. But we could hear it based on our own bias as, where should I avoid shopping so I don't get that shirt? That shirt looks cheap. That shirt, it doesn't go with you and you're coloring.
一种倾向，即去寻找、解释和回忆能够证实我们已有想法的信息。如果我们对某人形成了他是爱评判人的看法，即使是他们说的中性的话，我们也会将其解释为符合我们对他们的既定看法。他们可能会说：“嘿，你那件衬衫是在哪买的？”这是一个中立的问题。但根据我们自己的偏见，我们可能会把它听成：“我应该避免在哪里购物，免得买到那件衬衫？那件衬衫看起来很廉价。那件衬衫不适合你和你的肤色。”
Confirmation bias cements reputations by making people favor evidence supporting their views whilst ignoring contradictory data, meaning, again, first impressions or established beliefs about a person, are so difficult to change, whether it is fair or not. A 2022 study on how humans sample evidence to support prior beliefs concluded that this is likely because we don't like to be wrong. It takes too much cognitive effort to rewrite our whole opinion of someone, especially somebody we don't see or know that well. It takes a lot less effort to just confirm what we already think and say. That's who they are. The second bias is,
确认偏见通过让人们偏爱支持其观点的证据，同时忽视矛盾的数据来巩固名声，这意味着，无论公平与否，对一个人的第一印象或既定信念都极其难以改变。一项关于人类如何抽样证据来支持先验信念的2022年研究得出结论，这很可能是因为我们不喜欢出错。重写我们对某人的全部看法需要太多的认知努力，特别是对于那些我们不太常见到或不太了解的人。要证实我们已经想好的事情并说“这正是他们的本性”，所需的努力要少得多。第二个偏见是，
is recency bias. This is when we over-emphasize recent events, recent information, recent historical data more than perhaps data that is more accurate. This is what I was talking about before. I cringe. I literally lay awake at night thinking that somebody's last impression of me was formed when I was 18 and stupid and the worst version of myself and not reflective of the person I am now. I'm older, I'm wiser, I've been to therapy for many, many hours. And you want to go back and you want to say to them, like, trust me, like, I'm not that person anymore, I'm better than this, I promise you, but you can't. You can't, and actually doing that would be harmful.
近因偏见。这是指我们过度强调最近的事件、最近的信息、最近的历史数据，而可能超过了那些更准确的数据。这就是我之前谈到的。我感到尴尬。我 literalmente（字面意思）夜不能寐，想着别人对我的最后印象是在我18岁、愚蠢且处于最糟糕的自我状态时形成的，而这并不能反映现在的我。我更大了，更聪明了，我做了很多很多个小时的心理治疗。你想要回去对他们说，相信我，我不再是那个人了，我比这更好，我向你保证，但你做不到。你做不到，而且那样做实际上会有害。
You just have to be okay with someone's last impression of you being the worst version of you you ever were and trying not to think about it too much. And just knowing that's just how they see things. You can't always find it. It's human psychology. The most recent information we have access to, to us is the best information. According to our brain is the best information, regardless of whether there is newer, better information out there that we just haven't sought out or we just don't have access to.
你只需要接受别人对你的最后印象就是你曾有过的最糟糕的自己，并尽量不要过多地去想它。只要知道这正是他们看待事物的方式。你并不总能找到它。这就是人类心理学。我们能够接触到的最新信息，对我们来说就是最好的信息。根据我们大脑的判断，这就是最好的信息，无论外面是否有我们只是没有去寻找或无法接触到的更新、更好的信息。
There are, of course, many consequences of this and consequences of having a bad reputation. And I also think we need to talk about how some of those are deserved. If someone does harm people and hurts people, if that is a consistent pattern, we want others to know to steer clear. That is a social good in many ways. Having a bad reputation and the consequences of that also makes people realize their errors. A bad reputation is a form of social correction that requires people to do better and have accountability. That's another way that people see it. I think the hardest part is the instances where a bad reputation,
当然，这有很多后果，拥有坏名声也有很多后果。而且我也认为我们需要讨论其中一些后果是罪有应得的。如果有人确实伤害了别人，如果这是一种持续的模式，我们希望别人知道以保持距离。这在许多方面是一种社会福祉。拥有坏名声及其带来的后果也让人认清自己的错误。坏名声是一种社会纠正形式，要求人们做得更好并承担责任。这是人们看待它的另一种方式。我认为最难的部分是坏名声的那些情况，
is undeserved, right? We can spend a lot of time talking about why a bad reputation is deserved, but anybody who's experienced character assassination from a friend, a colleague, a family member, and ex, knows that when someone wants to ruin your life and ruin your reputation, there are many effective ways they can do that. And the pain that causes alongside the unspoken paranoia that isn't mentioned very often is intense. You're always worried like, my God, who have they spoken to? Like, what false narratives have they spread? Like, you meet people and you're like, have you heard, have they gotten to you first? Like, have they gotten to you before my actions have had the chance to? And this can lead to a lot of isolation and also a lot of self-doubt. Like,
是罪不至此的，对吧？我们可以花很多时间讨论为什么坏名声是罪有应得的，但任何经历过来自朋友、同事、家人、前任的人格谋杀的人都知道，当有人想要毁掉你的生活和名声时，他们有很多有效的方法可以做到这一点。它所带来的痛苦，以及不常被提及的、未说出口的偏执，是极其剧烈的。你总是会担心：天哪，他们都跟谁说过话？他们散布了什么虚假的故事？就像你遇到别人时会想：你听说了吗？他们是不是比我的行动更快一步找到你了？这会导致大量的孤立感，也会带来很多的自我怀疑，比如：
maybe I am who they say I am. Like, how can I trust myself? And that quickly spirals into a lot of self-gaslighting. Character assassination is often discussed in psychology, mainly in regards to political psychology and media psychology and how false messages spread through these avenues and spread through media and the news and whatnot. But it happens on an everyday basis all their time. So when we return, let's discuss this critical point why we can't trust everything we hear about people, the psychology of second chances, and when, if ever, we should address our negative reputation. Stay with us. Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave, Netflix, and Disney Plus from $94 a month.
也许我就是他们说的那种人？我怎么能信任自己？这很快就会演变成大量的自我精神控制。在心理学中经常讨论人格谋杀，主要涉及政治心理学和媒体心理学，以及虚假信息是如何通过这些途径传播的，又是如何通过媒体、新闻等等传播的。但它一直在日常生活中发生。所以当我们回来时，让我们讨论这个关键点：为什么我们不能相信关于人们的一切传闻、第二次机会的心理学，以及我们何时（如果有的话）应该应对我们的负面名声。请继续收听。获取 Bell 纯光纤网络并搭配 Crave、Netflix 和迪士尼 Plus，每月只需 94 加元起。
Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who lived through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming.
两年期网络合约加自动付款优惠，价格享受两年保障。访问 bell.ca 了解详情并查询可用性。Bell，连接意味着一切。我 14 岁时被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，并用一生探索其他人是如何在理应毁灭他们的事情中生存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这些是“幸存者档案”。我只记得耳边那个低沉、嘲弄的声音说：“闭嘴，什么也别说。”每周，我都会和那些经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问他会伤害我。我开始觉得床头站着一个人，然后我就开始尖叫。
They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part bookbookbooking.
他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被剥夺了声音。但这些故事不是关于他们被夺走了什么，而是关于活着逃出来需要付出什么。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这就是 Prose Society，这个每周播客既是读书俱乐部，
Club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling. characters and that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a
又是思想女孩、流行文化痴迷者以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《真爱岛》应该获得同等水平讨论的人的群聊。我是伊莉·拉罗（Eli Rallo），每周我们都在书籍、互联网以及每个人都在热烈讨论的话题之间建立联系。我得去查查这个故事。我太痴迷了。我太痴迷了。从畅销书作家和您最喜欢的 BookTok 创作者到最新的流行文化时刻，一切皆有可能。这就好比你在引人入胜的角色中隐藏了一些真实的信息，而这就是一个特洛伊木马。无论您是在寻找文学深度探讨、明智的流行文化对话，还是
community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is off. bring me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept
一个喜欢过度思考的读者社区，您都来对地方了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Pro Society。我们在字里行间相见。在全新播客 Solita 中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项 B。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我一个人旅行，因为这是一个难得的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性换取同情。每次我试图独自一人时，我总是
meeting people and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Hollywood Handbook on the Big Money Players Network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz,
遇到人，他们会说：“你对我们笑了。这附近可没多少人笑。”正是在你孤独的时候，你对世界的本来面目最具有接受力，而不是对关于它的那些谎言。这可能是一段突破极限、改变想法或唤醒全新自我的时期。因此，无论您是独自旅行的老手，还是紧张得不敢预订第一次旅行，我都希望您能在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Solita。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们在 Big Money Players 网络上主持播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。我们的节目对初次听众非常友好。我们与演艺界（也就是“圈内”）的人交谈，
and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time, and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman. Not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this?
并试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人对他们的公关允许他们上我们的节目感到生气。我们有很多出色的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼（Sarah Sherman）。没那么出色。事实上，你能帮我塑造一下这个吗？
How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip this script? What is the surprise woman? Actually, you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird. Adam Scott. this entire time you've been expecting
我们把它翻转过来怎么样，对吧？我们把这个剧本翻转一下怎么样？你认为实际上是直男的惊艳女性其实才是表现得很奇怪的那个人。亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）。这段时间你一直期待着
Adam Sandler to come to visit the show I would never let go of that I have I would never set expectations for something like that to happen if the universe allows for something like that to happen
亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）来做客节目我绝不会放弃这一点，我从未对会发生那样的事情设定过期望如果宇宙允许发生那样的事情
I'm open to it I'm always going to accept you know Danny McBride fine yeah it's all this fragile masculinity exuding I could smell it walking down the hallway to be honest with you I was like, is that weed?
我持开放态度我总是会接受的，你知道的，丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）很好，是的，这全都是散发着脆弱的男子气概我走廊走过来时就能闻到老实说我觉得，那是大麻吗？
Nope. It's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? They're like, oh, what's a state. Everyone's so dumb. And fake.
不。那是脆弱的男子气概。本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），不。因为很多时候脱离了语境，人们根本无法理解，甚至不知道什么是圆圈。你知道我的意思吗？他们会说，哦，什么是状态。每个人都太蠢了。而且虚假。
Right, fake and also not interested. Or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally, He loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
没错，虚假而且不感兴趣。或者只是像，哦，我有我自己的生活。我才不管你的生活呢。还有许多其他的大人物，如果没有我们，他们就不会有今天的成就。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）亲自告诉我们，他非常喜欢这个节目，他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他实在是太忙了。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。
So following on from what we spoke about before the break, should we always believe somebody else's reputation, especially if we don't know them, is that a wise social decision? I think it's worth thinking about who your source is and how they position the narrative around this individual who you know or maybe don't know that well. Firstly, people's opinions of others, again, are filtered through their own lens of characteristics and experiences and the kind of things they prefer or they don't like in other people. Reputation is a powerful tool, but it can be distorted by gossip, by jealousy, by malice.
那么接着我们中场休息前谈论的话题，我们是否应该总是相信别人的名声，尤其是当我们不了解他们的时候？这是一个明智的社会决定吗？我认为值得思考的是你的信息源是谁，以及他们如何围绕这个你认识或可能不太了解的个人来构建叙事。首先，人们对其他人的看法，同样是通过他们自身的性格和经历的镜头进行过滤的，以及他们在其他人身上偏爱或不喜欢的事情。名声是一个强大的工具，但它会被八卦、嫉妒和恶意所扭曲。
So is your source someone who would benefit from you thinking a certain way about this other person? that can be worth considering. Additionally, how does this person speak about people generally? Positively, negatively. I think we all have that one person in our lives. At least I think we all have this one person in our lives who is just pessimistic about everyone. You can be the most angelic kind individual.
那么，你的信息源是一个会因为你对另一个人产生某种看法而受益的人吗？这或许值得考虑。此外，这个人平时是怎么谈论别人的？积极的还是消极的？我想我们每个人的生活中都有这样一个人。至少我认为我们每个人的生活中都有这样一个人，他对所有人都悲观。你可以是最天安、善良的个人，
They will have something bad to say about you. Now, does that mean that everybody they possibly meet could be so evil? probably not. So you need to really closely consider their words and know what kind of person they are before you judge what kind of person they're describing. I think whilst a reputation can offer a general guide, it's also often wise to rely on your own personal experiences of a person. And if necessary, verify through evidence rather than the other way around, or rather through the rumor mill. Now, this is difficult because we don't want to fall into the position of like, we don't want to be the person who's like, well, they were always nice to me. Like, don't be that person. Especially if it's a
他们也还是会对你说三道四。现在，这是否意味着他们可能遇到的每个人都那么邪恶？可能并非如此。因此，在你评判他们所描述的那种人之前，你需要非常仔细地斟酌他们的话，并了解他们是什么样的人。我认为，虽然名声可以提供一个大致的指南，但依赖自己对一个人的亲身经历通常也是明智的。如果有必要，通过证据来核实，而不是反过来，或者说通过流言蜚语来核实。现在，这很困难，因为我们不想陷入这样的立场：我们不想成为那种说“嗯，他们对我都挺好”的人。别做那种人。特别是如果有
close friend saying, like, this person hurt me and they are not apologetic and I can't be around them. Listen to them. Use your judgment wisely. Like, don't disregard that. But if what you are hearing is from a distant source, an untrustworthy source, and they can't give examples, and they seem to be almost gleeful in their retelling, and they really seem to benefit from this, just take a step back. and trust your gut and use your better judgment. The other thing to consider, the evidence somebody is giving for this person's awful character, how recent is it?
密友说：“这个人伤害了我，他们没有悔意，我无法和他们在一起。”听取他们的意见。明智地使用你的判断力。不要忽视这一点。但如果你听到的消息来自远距离的来源、不可信的来源，而且他们无法举出例子，并且在复述时似乎幸灾乐祸，并且他们似乎真的从中受益，那就退后一步。倾听你的直觉，运用你更好的判断力。另一件需要考虑的事情是，别人为这个人的糟糕人品所提供的证据有多新鲜？
And when did these actions occur? Think about when you hear this, whether you'd like to be judged by information from that long ago in your own life. For example, I had somebody tell me the other day that I shouldn't work with this specific person who they'd known at 15 because she had a bad reputation for being unstable. Firstly, I hate the word unstable, and I was kind of cringed when they said it.
这些行为是什么时候发生的？想想当你听到这个时，你是否愿意被你生活中那么久远的信息所评判。例如，前几天有人告诉我，我不应该和这个特定的人合作，她在 15 岁时就认识她，因为她名声不好，很不稳定。首先，我讨厌“不稳定”这个词，当他们说出这个词时，我有点感到尴尬。
But secondly, I was kind of like, would you want to be judged by who you were at 15? Like, would you even recognize who you were at 15? Like, would you even know what they were thinking about? Probably not. Now, this obviously stands from a larger debate that humanity has been having for centuries, which is, can people truly change? And we're not going to answer that completely in this 45-minute episode. But I think you guys know me by now, and I think you guys know my relentless optimism about
但其次，我有点像：你愿意被你 15 岁时的样子所评判吗？就像，你甚至能认出 15 岁的自己吗？就像，你甚至知道他们在想什么吗？可能不会。现在，这显然源于人类几个世纪以来一直在进行的一个更大的争论，即：人真的能改变吗？我们不会在这集 45 分钟的节目中彻底回答这个问题。但我认为你们现在都了解我，我想你们也知道我对
the human condition. And honestly, I believe they can. And I believe that if the mistake somebody made was 10 years ago and it wasn't that big of a deal, they probably have learned from it. The best accurate indicator for someone's real character is consistent. behavior over time and their personal commitment to growth rather than just one specific way of behaving a very long time ago or at a very specific moment, especially if that is not a significant moral indicator or value indicator. With that in mind, what do we do when you feel like you are the
人类境况的不懈乐观。老实说，我相信他们可以。而且我相信，如果某人犯下的错误是在 10 年前，而且也不是什么大不了的事，他们很可能已经从中吸取了教训。衡量一个人真正性格的最佳准确指标是随着时间推移的持续行为以及他们对个人成长的承诺，而不是仅仅局限于很久以前或某个特定时刻的某种特定行为方式，特别是如果这并非一个重大的道德指标或价值观指标。考虑到这一点，当我们觉得自己就是
person I am describing? You are the person with a bad reputation. Perhaps you recognize that past behavior, your past behavior has really hurt people and you want to do better. Perhaps with wisdom, you know, you've realized, hey, I was in the wrong that whole time. Like, I made bad calls. Do we go about begging people forgiveness? Or do we take a different approach? The biggest thing you should know is that asking someone to think about you differently is nothing compared to showing people that you are different. And doing so independently and genuinely.
我正在描述的那个人时，我们该怎么办？你就是那个名声不好的人。也许你认识到过去的表现，你过去的行为确实伤害了别人，并且你想做得更好。也许随着智慧的增长，你知道的，你意识到，嘿，我从头到尾都错了。比如，我做出了糟糕的决定。我们要去乞求别人的原谅吗？还是采取不同的方法？你最应该知道的是，要求别人对你刮目相看，与向人们展示你是不同的相比，根本算不了什么。而且要独立、真诚地做到这一点。
that is the best thing you can do. Mike Mooney, he is the author of a book called The Reputation Shift. He says that if you want to change your reputation, it, quote, all starts with values. Because the authentic link between what someone stands for and what actions they will take is the most reliable. We need to commit to what we believe in and we need to live it minute by minute as best. as we can. Decide, you know, who am I going to be? Who do I not want to be? And stick with it. And when you do drop the ball from time to time, because we're human, we're fallible, just remember that most
那是你能做的最好的事情。迈克·穆尼（Mike Mooney），他是《名声转变》（The Reputation Shift）一书的作者。他说，如果你想改变你的名声，它“一切都始于价值观”。因为一个人所代表的立场与他将采取的行动之间的真实联系是最可靠的。我们需要对我们的信仰做出承诺，并且我们需要尽我们所能，分分秒秒地践行它。决定，你知道的，我要成为谁？我不想成为谁？并坚持下去。当你时不时地把事情搞砸时，因为我们是人，我们会犯错，只需记住，大多数
things are fixable if we own up to it. Own your actions, own your words, acknowledge what you did wrong. And make a promise to yourself before you make a promise to others to commit to being better and to commit to being better because you don't want to be the guy or the gal or the person who influences other people's experiences in a negative way. In addition, when we try and mend our reputations, it can be very easy to think that it just involves an apology. Apologies are very easy. Improving yourself, even when nobody asked, is much, much more valuable. It can be hard to confront, like, that, hey, maybe I was in the wrong, but your reputation will never improve by trying to fix your reputation if there is genuinely something that you are responsible for
事情只要我们勇于承担，都是可以挽回的。对你的行为负责，对你的话负责，承认你做错了什么。在对别人做出承诺之前，先对自己做出承诺，承诺变得更好，承诺变得更好是因为你不想成为那个以负面方式影响他人体验的家伙、姑娘或那个人。此外，当我们试图修复我们的名声时，很容易认为这只涉及道歉。道歉非常容易。自我提升，即使没有人要求，也具有极其巨大的价值。去面对“嘿，也许我错了”这件事可能会很艰难，但如果你确实负有某种责任却
that you cannot own up to. It doesn't mean that those things need to be your destiny. I think that's why we don't like to acknowledge them. But our brains are amazingly neuroplastic. Like, acknowledging something is what means that you can change that thing. We learn to change through being open with ourselves about what it is that we actually don't like or want to improve and committing to that. I think that's also one of the benefits of a bad reputation. When you get to the point of being like, oh my God, I messed up. Maybe I am that person. No one expects better of you. So you kind of have the peace you need to actually do the work. But also, you get a wake-up call that some people never get or will never listen to. That maybe I'm not the person I think I am.
不敢承认，那么仅仅通过试图修复名声，你的名声是永远不会改善的。这并不意味着这些事情必须成为你的命运。我想这就是为什么我们不喜欢承认它们的原因。但我们的大脑具有惊人的神经可塑性。承认某事意味着你可以改变那件事。我们通过对自己坦诚相待来学会改变，坦承我们实际上不喜欢什么或想要改进什么，并致力于此。我认为这也是坏名声的好处之一。当你到了这样一种地步：“天哪，我搞砸了。也许我真的是那种人。”没有人对你有更高的期望。所以你拥有了真正开始工作所需的平静。但同时，你也得到了某些人永远得不到或永远不会听取的警钟：
maybe I'm not that great, but at least I have the opportunity to be better. Some people never get that choice and they just assholes for their whole lives. Additionally, I think there also comes a point where ruminating, obsessing, and overcorrecting for your reputation imagined or real will just do more damage than good. Specifically to you, nobody improves from a place of shame. They only improve from a place of acceptance. Your shame and your guilt and you hiding away isn't helping you. and it isn't helping the people that you have hurt.
也许我并不是自己想象中的那种人，也许我没那么伟大，但至少我有机会变得更好。有些人永远没有这种选择，他们一辈子都是混蛋。此外，我认为还会出现这样一个时刻：对你想象中或真实的坏名声进行反刍、痴迷和过度纠正，只会带来更多的破坏而非建设。特别是对你而言，没有人能从耻辱感中获得提升。他们只能从接纳中获得提升。你的羞耻感、你的内疚感以及你的躲藏并没有帮到你。也没有帮到那些被你伤害过的人。
Like, to just continually think badly of yourself and think that's going to make you a better person, you would be wrong. Fundamentally as well, like, you know who you are and you know that this was a mistake, you know your intentions, we know our own guilt, we know that we feel bad, we know what we want to improve on, whether others think we're capable of it or not, whether others have made up false stories about us or not. our reputations are inevitably not always up to us. And I think that's why you sometimes need to just take a step back from it and be like,
就像，仅仅不断地贬低自己并认为这会让你成为一个更好的人，那你就大错特错了。从根本上说，就像，你知道你是谁，你知道这是一个错误，你知道你的意图，我们知道自己的内疚，我们知道我们感觉不好，我们知道我们想要改进什么，不管别人是否认为我们有能力做到，不管别人是否对我们编造了虚假的故事。我们的名声不可避免地并不完全由我们决定。我想这就是为什么有时你只需要退后一步，然后想：
what do I think about me and what do the people closest to me think about me? We tend to worry about our reputations because we think that everybody is thinking about us all the time. And we think that our reputations are reflective of our true identities. and that's why we chronically ruminate. And it just isn't a good use of our time. Worrying about what other people think when you have made a commitment to being better or when you know who you are
我对自己的看法是什么，最亲近的人对我的看法是什么？我们往往会担心自己的名声，因为我们觉得每个人都在无时无刻地关注着我们。我们认为我们的名声反映了我们的真实身份。这就是我们长期反刍的原因。这根本不是对我们时间的有效利用。当你已经承诺要变得更好，或者当你真正了解自己时，担心别人怎么想
actually stops you from being able to be that person. Do you know what I mean? Like the obsession with reputation is what probably leads to a worse reputation because you get lost from what is critical and deep and intrinsic about you. If you are feeling suffocated by others' opinions,
实际上会阻碍你成为那样的人。你知道我的意思吗？就像对名声的痴迷可能正是导致更坏名声的原因，因为你迷失了对你而言至关重要、深刻和本质的东西。如果你感到被别人的意见压得喘不过气来，
I think it's important to wrap, write down who you would be if they all disappeared and who you would want to be if they were nowhere to be found and their influence on your life as non-existence. Focus on the people who love you, who know that your character is pure, focus on pouring energy into them, focus on the people who know that you can change or who love you the way that you are. When we have clarity over who we are, including perhaps the things we want to improve on, we can ignore our temporary mistakes and setbacks in the knowledge that we are a work in progress, we are somebody who is trying their best, and that actually counts for a lot more than a good reputation that is based
我认为重要的是总结一下，写下如果所有人消失了你会是谁，如果他们无影无踪且他们对你生活的影响荡然无存你想成为谁。专注于那些爱你的人，那些知道你品格纯洁的人，专注于将精力倾注在他们身上，专注于那些知道你可以改变或以本来的面目爱你的人。当我们对我是谁有清晰的认识时，包括可能包括我们想要改进的地方，我们可以忽略暂时的错误和挫折，因为我们知道我们是一个正在进行中的项目，我们是一个尽力而上的人，这实际上比建立在虚假基础上的好名声更有分量。
in falsities. So that, my friends, is the psychology of reputation. I do hope that it had enough nuance in it. I did want to consider all perspectives, and I hope to the listener who wrote in that we adequately answered your question. I think to summarize, reputation matters. People who only rely on reputation, though, are falling for a lot of cognitive biases and fallacies. If somebody has a bad reputation, you know, yes, if it's consistent behavior and it's accurate, very much worth listening to. There are people who you better believe deserve a bad reputation, if not a worse reputation. but it's also important to be critical of where we're hearing that information from, who benefits from that information, whether it is accurate,
所以，我的朋友们，这就是名声的心理学。我确实希望它包含足够的细微差别。我确实想考虑所有的观点，我希望写信来的听众我们已经充分回答了你的问题。我想总结一下，名声很重要。然而，只依赖名声的人是在陷入大量的认知偏差和谬误。如果某人名声不好，你知道的，是的，如果是持续的行为并且准确，非常值得倾听。有些人你最好相信他们罪有应得，甚至罪有应得更坏的名声。但同样重要的是，要对我们从哪里听到这些信息、谁从这些信息中受益、它是否准确保持批判的态度，
and holistically believe that people can change, and that if we were to believe that everybody is the mistakes they made at 17 and 18, especially minor mistakes, like none of us are worth saving, none of us deserve a good reputation. So if you are kind of ruminating on like, oh my God, people still think that I am this person and I've done these bad things and am I allowed to even be happy? Am I allowed to even try to be better? Absolutely you do. And whether that is a gateway to a better reputation or not, it doesn't matter because you will feel more aligned with who you are and you
并全面地相信人是会变的，如果我们认为每个人都是他们在 17 岁和 18 岁时犯下的错误（尤其是微小的错误），那么我们中就没有一个人是值得拯救的，我们中也没有一个人配得上好名声。所以，如果你一直在反刍诸如“天哪，人们仍然认为我是这个人，我做了这些坏事，我甚至配拥有快乐吗？我甚至配尝试变得更好吗？”之类的问题，你绝对配。不管这是否通往更好名声的大门，这都不重要，因为你会感觉更贴近真实的自我，并且
will feel more like your real self. So that is the end of the episode. Thank you for listening. Thank you to our researcher Lucy Davidson for her assistance with this episode. I really hope that you guys enjoyed it. I really hope that you appreciate it did not make a Taylor Swift reputation reference or joke throughout this whole episode. I was trying to find a way to bring it in and you know what, it just never happened. We were being too serious. But yeah, I hope you enjoyed it. I hope it's helped you. Somebody who also struggles with this sometimes, like, I think we should talk about it more and why reputation is like this really weird thing that we think about actually very, very often and never talk about.
你会更觉得自己像个真实的人。好了，本期节目到此结束。谢谢收听。感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）对本期节目的协助。我真心希望你们会喜欢。我真心希望你们能欣赏到我在整期节目中都没有提及泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）的名声（Reputation）梗或开玩笑。我曾试图寻找一种方法把它带进来，你知道吗，它就是没发生。我们当时太严肃了。但是，是的，我希望你喜欢它。我希望它能帮到你。作为一个有时也会为此挣扎的人，我觉得我们应该更多地谈论它，以及为什么名声是一件我们经常思考却从不谈论的非常奇怪的事情。
So, yeah, if you relate to this episode, leave a comment down below. Make sure that you check out an episode on Netflix. If you feel called to do so, we've just like redone the set and it looks really, really cool. And I'm very excited about it. But yeah, there'll be links in the description. I hope you go check it out. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself.
所以，是的，如果你对这期节目深有同感，请在下方留言。如果你觉得有必要的话，一定要去看看 Netflix 上的节目。我们刚刚重新布置了布景，看起来真的很酷。我对此感到非常兴奋。但是，是的，描述中会有链接。我希望你去看看。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。
Don't worry all too much about your reputation, especially if you are trying to be better. That is the takeaway. And we will talk very, very soon. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the I-HeartPert.
不要过分担心你的名声，尤其是当你正努力变得更好时。这就是核心要点。我们很快就会再次交谈。我被囚禁了九个月并活了下来，我花了一生时间探索其他人是如何在理应毁灭他们的事情中生存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这些是“幸存者档案”。每周，我都会和那些经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起，他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被剥夺了声音。这些是关于活着逃出来需要付出什么的故事。在 I-Heart 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。
radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed.
radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。Pro Society 是一个每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊，适合所有认为《傲慢与偏见》和《真爱岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、BookTok 创作者以及大量过度思考的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化联系起来。是的，我太痴迷了。
That's so obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
简直太痴迷了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Pro Society。在全新播客 Solita 中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项 B。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我一个人旅行，因为这是一个难得的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性换取同情。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Solita。
I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville, a battle for the future of America, plays out in one small town.
我是霍达·科特布（Hoda Kotb），播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》的主持人。你知道的，我一直在寻找灵感和有用的工具来最大化快乐。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒（Henry Winkler）向有志演员以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提供的建议一样。你被雇用不只是为了填补时间和空间。你被雇用是为了用你自己来填补这个空间。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb。我们的家乡可不是试管。在纳什维尔东北部 90 英里处，一场关于美国未来的战役在一个小镇上演。
Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land. We need cities on a shining hill. This is our town. A podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to Our Town on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拥有右翼背景的开发商已经购买了数百英亩土地。我们需要山巅之城。这是我们的镇。一个关于当一个小镇成为社会实验场并发起反抗时会发生什么的播客。我想你们搬进来时没料到会遇到一群笨山民吧？在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Our Town。这是一档 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。